[Music]
black holes are among the most
destructive objects in the universe
anything that gets too close to the
central singularity of a black hole be
it an asteroid planet or star risks
being torn apart by its extreme
gravitational field and if the
approaching object happens to cross the
black hole's event horizon it'll
disappear and never really the black
hole's mass and expanding its radius in
the process there is nothing we could
throw at a black hole that would do the
least bit of damage to it even another
black hole won't destroy it the two will
simply merge into a larger black hole
releasing a bit of energy as
gravitational waves in the process by
some accounts it's possible that the
universe may eventually consists
entirely of black holes in a very
distant future and yet there may be a
way to destroy or evaporate these
objects after all if the theory is true
all we need to do is to wait in 1974
Stephen Hawking theorized a process that
could lead a black hole to gradually
lose mass Hawking radiation as it came
to be known is based on a
well-established phenomenon called
quantum fluctuations of the vacuum
according to quantum mechanics a given
point in space-time fluctuates between
multiple possible energy states these
fluctuations are driven by the
continuous creation and destruction of
virtual particle pairs which consists of
a particle and its oppositely charged
anti particle normally the two collide
and annihilate each other shortly after
appearing preserving the total energy
but what happens when they appeared just
at the edge of a black hole's event
horizon if they're positioned just right
one of the particles could escape the
black hole's pull while its counterpart
falls in it would then annihilate
another oppositely charged particle
within the event horizon of the black
hole reducing the black hole's mass
meanwhile to an outside observer it
would look like the black hole had
emitted the escaped part of
thus unless a black hole continues to
absorb additional matter and energy
it'll evaporate particle by particle at
an excruciatingly ly slow rate how slow
a branch of physics called black hole
thermodynamics gives us an answer when
everyday objects or celestial bodies
release energy to their environment we
perceive that as heat and can use their
energy emission to measure their
temperature black hole thermodynamics
suggests that we can similarly define
the temperature of a black hole it
theorizes that the more mass of the
black hole the lower its temperature the
universe's largest black holes would
give off temperatures of the order of 10
to the negative 17th power Kelvin very
close to absolute zero meanwhile one
with the mass of the asteroid Vesta
would have a temperature close to 200
degrees Celsius thus releasing a lot of
energy in the form of Hawking radiation
to the cold outside environment the
smaller the black hole the hotter it
seems to be burning and the sooner it'll
burn out completely just how soon well
don't hold your breath first of all most
black holes accrete or absorb matter and
energy more quickly than they emit
Hawking radiation but even if a black
hole with the mass of our Sun stopped
accreting it would take 10 to the 67th
power years many many magnitudes longer
than the current age of the universe to
fully evaporate when a black hole
reaches about 230 metric tons
it'll have only one more second to live
in that final second its event horizon
becomes increasingly tiny until finally
releasing all of its energy back into
the universe and while Hawking radiation
has never been directly observed some
scientists believe that certain
gamma-ray flashes detected in the sky
are actually traces of the last moments
of small primordial black holes formed
at the dawn of time
eventually in an almost inconceivably
distant future the universe may be left
as a cold and dark place but if Stephen
Hawking was right before that happens
the normally terrifying and otherwise
impervious black holes will end their
existence in a final blaze of glory how
did our universe begin how will it end
and just how many universes are there
keep contemplating the mysteries of
space with this playlist
[Music]